mieux qu'un stage de troisième une
journée découverte avec l'association
l'Outil en Main d'un côté des jeunes de
9 à 15 ans de l'autre des artisans
retraités des heureux de faire découvrir
leur ancien métier coiffure retaille de
pierre ou encore électricité la dernière
session avait lieu cette semaine au
centre de formation des apprentis des
Compagnons du Devoir à tourneur
il y a quelques heures encore ces
enfants ignoraient l'existence de la
massette ou même de la gouge pour
tailler une pierre leur quotidien
normalement c'est l'école ou le collège
mais aujourd'hui il découvre les métiers
manuels c'est le cas de Jean 13 ans
depuis le début de la matinée il apprend
à façonner une pierre de tuffeau une
expérience inédite parfois un peu
physique je trouve ça intéressant parce
que j'en avais jamais fait et puis aussi
je trouve que ça ça nous apprend des
trucs de d'essayer plusieurs
cordes métiers et de faire des
expériences comme ça
dans cette nouvelle salle quatre autres
ateliers ici on teste par exemple
l'électricité ou la coiffure à chaque
fois les enfants sont encadrés par des
artisans à la retraite ou désireux de
transmettre leur savoir-faire
Marie-Cécile a été couturière son compte
pendant 17 ans elle apprend les
rudiments du métier à Clotilde 12 ans
l'objectif de la matinée de réaliser une
pochette en tissu avec une machine à
coudre
oui je suis un peu surprise quand même
je pensais pas que j'allais faire ça
mais je vais pouvoir le refaire à la
maison j'aime bien rencontrer des gens
pour qui nous apprennent leur métier et
j'aime bien apprendre d'autres métiers
que je connais pas pour l'instant
l'association l'Outil en Main était
bergée par les compagnons du devoir mais
dès septembre elle proposera ce type
d'atelier dans ses propres locaux près
de l'ancienne base aérienne à Tours Nord
ça se passera le mercredi après-midi
pendant l'année scolaire
deux heures tous les mercredis
après-midi
chaque métier a une manipulation à une
façon de travailler à une façon de faire
à un art
d'ici là une nouvelle journée de
découverte des métiers manuels aura lieu
aux vacances de Pâques plus
d'informations inscriptions et tarifs
sur le site internet de l'association
OM tour.fr
un